In this final lesson, let's take
what we learned in the previous
lesson and add on to it to
create a conversational agent.
This will combine tool
usage with chat memory and let
us create something that
ends up looking like ChatGPT.
Let's chat about conversational agents.
In this lesson, we'll be
building a conversational agent.
First, let's go over the basics of agents.
So what are agents?
They're a combination of
language models and code.
So the language model
reasons about what steps to take
and what the inputs to
those actions should be,
and then there's an agent loop which
basically uses that agent to choose the tool,
and then it calls that
tool, observes the output,
What are these stopping
criterias? They could be several things.
The first and most
popular one is just using
the language model to
determine when to stop.
So if you remember the previous lesson,
we talked about the idea of an agent finish.
This is when the
language model just responds.
This is one such stopping criteria.
But you can have others
like hard-coded rules,
such as the maximum number of
iterations or something like that.
In this lab, we're going to use the
tools that we built in the previous lesson.
We're going to take that concept of
routing and choosing and then calling the tools,
and we're going to put
that into our own agent loop,
We're then going to use the
agent executor class in LangChain
We're then going to go
ahead and create the logic that
takes in the input and
determines what tool to call.
So we did this in the previous lesson.
So we're importing a
model, the prompt template,
the formatting of tools to open AI
functions, and then this output parser.
We're then going to create
functions by calling format
tool to open AI
function on our list of tools.
We're going to create our model,
setting temperature
equals equals to zero and
binding it with
functions equals functions.
We're then going to create our
prompt again pretty simple with just
a single system message you
are helpful but sassy assistant,
And so if we call this
on some input we can
get back a tool that it recommends using,
and the tool input. And again,
that's because the input here is
specifically aimed at calling one of the tools.
So what we want to do is create this
loop that determines what tool to use,
then calls that tool,
and passes it back in and
repeats until some
stopping criteria is met.
If you look at the prompt,
what that means is we need a place
in the prompt to pass back in this
history of tools that are called
and the corresponding outputs.
So we're going to have to change the
prompt a little bit to add that in.
Specifically, we want to add in a place
where we can pass in a list of messages.
And that's because we're going
to convert this tool selection to
tool observation into a list of
messages and pass it back in.
So we're going to use
messages placeholder to
be a placeholder for
this list of messages.
And then in our prompt template, we're
going to have the same first two elements,
but then we're going to add in this
agent scratchpad messages placeholder.
We create that prompt, we
create a chain now with this
prompt and let's call it
again on the same input.
And this time we also need
to pass in agent scratchpad,
because this is the variable
here that we need to pass in.
We're going to pass in
this being an empty list,
because we haven't taken any actions yet.
We'll call that, and we'll get result 1.
Then what we can do is we can see
what function result 1 wants us to call.
We can then call that function
and get back an observation.
If we look at this observation,
we can see that it is a string.
And of course, we have result one,
which is this agent action message log.
So now how are we going to take
these two things and convert them back
into a list of messages that we
can pass into agent scratchpad?
In order to do that, we're gonna use
this function, format to open AI functions,
Behind the scenes, what's going
on in format to open AI functions?
What's happening is that
we're gonna take result 1,
So if we look at it, this
contains the chat message
that has this additional quarks with this
function call saying
get current temperature
and then the arguments
with the JSON string,
the exact response from OpenAI.
And so we're keeping that around in this
message log because now when it comes time
to construct this agent scratch pad we
can just put it right back in there,
So we're going to call this
function and we're going to call it on a
list of tuples corresponding to the
agent action and the observation.
And the reason that this
is a list of tuples is that
if we add in more steps
for the agent to take we
can just keep on passing
in a list of tuples and
it will keep on
generating this list of messages.
So here we have an AI message and
this corresponds to what was outputted
by the language model to
make it take this agent action
and then we have this function
message with the content being
the observation and the name
being get current temperature.
If we then take that and call the chain
again with the same input and now with
agent scratchpad set equal to this
format to open AI functions parameter,
if we look at what we
get back from result 2,
So let's bundle all of
that up into a function.
So what we're going to do is we're
going to create this run agent function.
This is going to take in the user input.
It's going to initialize an empty
list. This is the intermediate steps.
And then it's going to
enter into a while loop.
And while this loop is running,
it's going to call the chain with this
user input and with this agent scratchpad.
And each time we're calling format
to open AI functions on this list
We're going to make one
minor modification to this chain
before continuing to
make it a true agent chain.
And basically what we're
going to do is we're going to put
this format to open AI
functions logic in the chain itself.
That's going to make it a
little bit more portable so it just
has to take in the user input
and the intermediate steps.
We're going to create this agent
chain by using a runnable pass-through.
What a runnable
pass-through does is it basically
takes the initial input
and passes it through.
What we're going to do is we're
going to add this assign variable here.
This assign method here
is creating a new argument
to the dictionary that's
getting passed through.
This argument has the name
agent scratchpad and this is where
we call format to open AI
functions on intermediate steps.
We're then going to pipe
the result of that which
is a dictionary into the chain and we're
going to get a full
end-to-end chain that now
takes in the input in intermediate steps,
does the necessary
pre-processing of the intermediate
steps to create the agent scratchpad,
then passes it to the
prompt, then to the model,
and then to the agent output parser.
With this change we can now create a
slightly more simple loop here where
if you notice we're just calling the
agent chain on the inputs directly,
Let's now run this agent. So let's
call it on what is the weather in SF?
And we get back the current temperature
in San Francisco is 22.9 Degrees Celsius.
If we run the agent now, we can
see that we get back a response.
And let's also call it on a simple
input. Let's call it on just hi.
Hello, how can I assist
you today? That seems right.
So we've created this run agent function,
which is this loop that loops
over the LLM, decides what to do,
then takes the next step.
We have a class for this in
LangChain called agent executor,
It adds in error handling.
So if the language model outputs
something that isn't valid JSON,
which remember it can still
do, we handle that nicely.
And it adds in also
error handling for tools.
So if you call a tool and the tool
errors, we then handle that nicely.
We catch that error. We
pass it back into the
language model and ask it to correct it.
We can use this pretty
simply by just importing
agent executor from langchain.agents.
We can then initialize this with
agent equals to the agent chain.
We pass in the tools because it needs
to have the tools to be able to call it,
and then we pass in verbose
equals true to get some nice logging.
If we now call this on what is LangChain,
This agent executor in
this loop under the hood is
very similar to a lot of
what's powering chat GPT.
So if you've interacted with the code
interpreter there or the plug-in system there,
you'll notice that the language
model often thinks about what to do,
then it calls a tool, then
it gets back the response,
then it maybe calls another one, then
it gets back the response from that,
and then it returns to the user.
So this is a really
powerful loop and technique that
can be used to create
something like ChatGPT.
Of course, what ChatGPT can also do is
it can also have a conversation with you.
So can we do that with our current
agent executor? Let's try it out.
So let's try it out with
something simple like my name is Bob.
So it responds. "Hello Bob,
how can I assist you today?"
Let's then ask it a
follow-up question that
any good chatbot should be able to answer.
So let's ask it, what is my name?
And I've just told it that my name is
Bob, but it doesn't seem to remember that.
So what's going on?
What's happening is that we
haven't added any mechanism
to actually pass in previous messages.
So it actually doesn't
remember the my name is Bob message.
Let's add that in and see
what happens after that.
In order to add that in, we're going
to add another messages placeholder,
this time for chat history.
This is going to be before the user input,
because we want to put messages
that have appeared before and so we're
going to put it in between the
system message and the user question.
We'll then create the same agent
chain as before with the updated prompt,
What this is going to do is it's just
going to keep a list of messages in memory.
We're going to return these
messages in message format. And basically,
If this was set to false, it
would return it as a string.
And so if we wanted to, we could get a
string representation of all these messages.
This would be useful if we wanted to
put that in a normal string template,
but here we don't. We want to
pass it in as a list of messages,
so we're setting return
messages equals true.
We're then also setting
memory key equals chat history.
This is just lining up the
messages that are returned
with this variable here so
it's keeping those in sync.
And then all we have
to do when creating our
agent executor is pass
in the updated chain,
pass in the same tools as before,
we're going to set verbose
equals to true as before,
and then we're also going to pass in
memory equals to the memory object above.
Let's now run this on the input as
before. So we're going to say, "Hi,
If we now ask what my name
is, it realizes my name is Bob.
Good.
And of course we can use it
as before and ask it about
the current weather and it
will know how to use a tool,
it will call that tool and
then we'll get back the response.
So this has the same
functionality as before but we've added in
this memory component that just
remembers previous interactions.
Now is a good time to pause and try
it out on some questions of your own,
try adding in some new tools, try
adding in a different system prompt.
There's a lot of different
things you can play around with here.
For our final bit here, we're
going to put it all together and
create a nice looking
chatbot that we can interact with.
Let's add in another tool.
You guys should feel free to
replace this with whatever you want.
Remember to update this
description here when you're done.
For us here we're just going to
have a really simple reverse operator
that's taking in the query
and just reversing the string.
We're going to update our list of tools,
Using a tool called panel, we're going to
create a nice little UI for this chatbot.
And so taking a look at this very briefly,
we can see here that
we have our functions,
which is calling the same function as
before, format tool to open AI functions.
We've got our model, which
is a chat open AI model,
and we're binding functions to it.
We've got memory, which is same as before.
We've got our prompt, which is same
as before. So it's got system message,
We're then creating the
agent chain, same as before.
And then we're creating the
agent executor, same as before.
With that in place, we can
now run panel and create
a nice little dashboard with a Q&A bot.
And so we can start
having a conversation with it.
So we can again do, hi, my name is Bob.
Press Enter and we can see it pop up.
What's my name?
Your name is Bob. We can ask
it questions about the weather.
What's the weather in SF.
See it takes a little bit
longer because now it's calling
a tool but it manages to get
the current temperature okay.
We can ask it some fun questions
like what tools do you have available.
So we can see that it lists out
the tools that it has available,
get current temperature,
search Wikipedia, create your own.
Let's now force it to
call the create your own.
So we're going to tell it to
call the create your own tool
with the input I love
LangChain and return the result.
So if we look at what happens,
the result of the create
your own tool with the input
I love LangChain is something that's
unpronounceable, but it looks right.
This is the end of the lesson. So
now's a great time to add in more tools,
try it out with different inputs. You've
got a chatbot that's similar to ChatGPT.
It can have a conversation, it can take
actions, you can see the results of that,
try making it do multiple hops.
There's a lot of amazing things that
you can try out and build and I really
look forward to seeing what you
guys build with this technology.